[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMIR SHEVAT: The vision is to
take two people, two types of
people, who like to
create things--
developers and artists-- and
create amazing projects over
Google technology.
YIFAT GURION: Where technology
and art meets,
exciting things happen.
And the partnership with
Google puts us
exactly at that spot.
TZVIKA MARKFELD: Developers
can learn something new.
And the artists can gain a new
experience of technology.
AMIR SHEVAT: So we have
seven projects.
They're really nice.
The feedback up until now
has been amazing.
SARON PAZ: The Action Painter is
an Android app that turns a
smartphone into a color brush,
which actually acts as a
creative extension
of your body.
TOMER DANIEL: We used the
Android application, which
samples accelerometer and
orientation devices.
And on the Chrome side, we're
actually doing the painting,
the four brushes that
we're painting with.
The Action Painter is a
social application.
And you can share your creation
with G+, with Google+.
OMER GOLAN: Plant a Comment is
a multidimensional virtual
world in which thoughts
grow into trees.
We asked people to send us a
text message saying anything
they liked about the event.
YUVAL ADAM: And once we receive
a sentence of one of
their thoughts, we would take
that and analyze it
semantically so that we are able
to group trees that talk
about the same subjects
together.
We use the input via text
messages or from Google+.
And then we analyze them using
Google prediction?
API and Google Translation APIs
and take all that and put
it on a 3D world, which
is rendered in WebGL.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: Dissolving
Localities is basically a web
interface, which allows the user
or the public to take a
tour of Jerusalem on Street View
with audio recordings of
the places on Street View.
And it's basically an artistic
tour of Jerusalem.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: It uses HTML5
features like cameras,
audio, and video tags.
It also uses Google Street
View and Google Maps API.
URI SHAKED: SoundTracker is a
way of making music by simply
walking around in a room.
TOM MEMAN: The more technical
breakdown is that Android
cameras film the people
inside the room.
Using that location, we
translate it into music.
Each instrument gets a different
translation.
AMIR SHEVAT: The Digital Art
Project aims to inspire
developers that they can do
amazing applications over our
technology.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: I think it's
a once in a lifetime
experience, being in
an art environment
with artistic people.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: I'm sort
of way out there.
And I need someone both
to sort of clarify
the idea that I--
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: Someone
down to earth.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: No, clarify
the ideas that I have and also
be able to--
MICHAEL SVERDLIN:
More practical.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM:
Yeah, thanks.
TOM MEMAN: I can't imagine doing
something like that if
it weren't for the collaboration
between Google
and Fresh Paint.
SARON PAZ: Suddenly I can get
a crazy idea, and these guys
will actually help me make it.
IDO GREEN: Hello, and welcome
to GDL again.
It's a special episode
on Devart.
We have a few of the main
dudes that created a
wonderful, amazing project
over there.
So let's let them maybe
introduce yourself.
URI SHAKED: All right.
So I am Uri Shaked.
I work for WatchDox and also
as lead of the local Google
Developer Group here
in Tel Aviv.
I'm also creating the Android
and the iOS applications in my
free time, dancing salsa,
teaching salsa to people, and
overall, having a lot of fun.
EMMANUEL WITZHUM: Fair enough.
My name is Emmanuel Witzthum.
And I'm an artist, a curator,
and project manager.
And yep, that's it.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: My name
is Michael Sverdlin.
I'm a developer, entrepreneur.
And I do the [INAUDIBLE]
work with Uri.
And I do fun things in my
free time, like the
Fresh Paint 5 project.
IDO GREEN: And talking
about the project.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: Yeah.
More projects like submarines.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IDO GREEN: So again watch it
if I missed it by mistake.
So let's just jump into the
order, and maybe the best
would be to start with
what is Devart?
What's it all about?
URI SHAKED: All right.
So Devart is mainly about
connecting the developers and
artists in order to create
some art with combining
technology, or better to say
make art by technology.
So the artists are able to
express themselves in new
ways, rather than the
traditional canvas and paint
or the traditional digital.
So the idea behind Devart is to
take artists who have ideas
of new ways to use technology in
order to deliver their art
and connect them with developers
who take part in
this project.
And they actually work together
to create the projects.
IDO GREEN: So maybe if you could
just share with us what
was the last Devart like and
why people should come
for the next one.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: I think that
we live in a time where
people want to participate.
They want to be active in
what they experience.
And I think that Devart
provides a wonderful
opportunity for problem solvers
and problem creators--
so problem creators as artists,
problem solvers as
developers--
to sort of create projects
in which people
don't come as a public.
They don't come to experience
something.
They come to use something.
And for me as an artist,
Devart was a phenomenal
experience exactly
because of this.
As an artist, somehow you
sometimes feel that you're in
one corner.
The public is another.
And we need someone
to say, OK, gong,
this the first round.
And in this sense for
me, the developers
were that first round.
Devart was this sort of ring,
where we could say, OK, we're
not in two corners.
We can actually be
the same place.
So I think that for me, Devart
was great because I could
think of an idea, talk with
Michael about it.
And then we develop something
together, thinking constantly
about the user.
Not thinking about the public,
not thinking about someone's
going to clap at the end, but
instead, how are they going to
interact with this?
How are they going to use it?
How are they going to
experience what we
want to say with them?
And then bring it back to us so
we can say, wait a second.
We could do this differently
the next time.
And so it's an ongoing process
as an artistic project
together with the developers.
IDO GREEN: I think it was very
fun to see how we're basically
closing the chasm between the
two worlds and creating some
pretty cool, inventive things.
I think that one aspect for me
as a developer was to see the
problem develop in an open
source project that just comes
flourishing after
what is well.
So there's one of the aspects
that is extremely compelling,
that you're starting something
with the idea, a
problem or a challenge.
And then it's moving on and on
and actually taking a life of
its own, which is
very, very nice.
Maybe you could tell us a bit
about the specific project or
problem that you solved.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: Sure.
Do you want to be it?
URI SHAKED: You go first.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: OK.
So two years ago, I created an
artist project in which I
tried to use the daily life of
Jerusalem as a source for art.
So just take people talking,
cars driving by, birds
chirping, and say, how can we
create art out of that?
The main reason for that was
because I wanted people to
experience life in Israel
in a more complex way.
And also because I wanted to
have artists interact with
life in Israel and also
artists interact
with life in general.
And so until now, we've created
live projects and done
installations, et cetera.
And then when the idea of
connecting this with Devart
came about, it became an
incredible experience of
thinking how to use
Google Street View
as an artistic tool.
Not necessarily to
say, oh, look.
That's [INAUDIBLE]
or that's the Old City.
But I say, how can I interact
with these places?
How can I create an artistic
tool of Jerusalem though
Google Street View?
And one of them-- the connection
was made with
[INAUDIBLE] and Michael
Sverdlin.
And both of them really sort
of helped me figure out
exactly what I wanted to
do because sometimes--
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: And
what's possible.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: That's
very true, very true.
Sometimes I can think
very, very high.
Michael's like, great.
OK.
Let's just talk about that.
Let's bring us back here.
IDO GREEN: Excellent, yeah.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: And it was
a really great distinction
because things had
to be concrete
in order to be realized.
And to me, that was a very
interesting platform to be in
because it can open
up the project in
many different ways.
And the end result was very,
very interesting to see.
IDO GREEN: So I'll try just
to summarize to see that I
understood and hopefully people
will understand it.
You combined 3D audio around
Google Maps, Google Street
View, to give the users an
impression of what's going on
in a city or an area or place.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: We
constructed artistic tours of
Jerusalem with sound of the
images that they saw on Google
Street, and then we created
videos out of
these specific tours.
And the audience could come,
and they could either
experience one tour, or they
could combine between
different tours together.
So different places in
Jerusalem, it had overlaid on
top of each other.
And then we created
musical loops that
accompanied the story.
And then you almost could
actually also engage by
changing the color,
having an effect.
It was like-- think
of an Instagram in
video sort of situation.
And they basically could see
life in Jerusalem from a sort
of unique perspective.
And that's what we
tried to do.
IDO GREEN: Excellent.
What were the main aspects
in terms of design?
I mean, what did you two take
in account when you started
those building blocks and
combining them together?
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: I'll talk
from my perspective.
It was very important for me
that the audience understand
the audience.
The people who come to
experience the project would
sort of understand immediately
what they were supposed to do.
So it was very important for me
that they understood that
they could interact with the
project, not only just come
and look at it and say,
OK, it's not moving.
You have to press in order
for it to start moving.
Because in Fresh Paint, people
who come to see artistic
projects usually think of
themselves as passive.
They come.
They look.
Then they move.
They move.
They look.
And Devart was great because
you see people--
in your project, they
were moving around.
In my project, the had to use
the mouse and sort of work
with what materials they
had, et cetera.
So people came a little bit
more ready to be active in
what they saw.
And for me, in terms of the
user experience and user
interface, it was very important
that I could provide
a doorway for them to
come inside there
and experience that.
IDO GREEN: Excellent.
And then from your perspective,
the user
experience needed to be as
simple as possible or
self-intuitive?
How did you act it in terms of
someone would explain to them
that they needed to click?
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: We had
a person that helped.
Our hostess was unbelievably--
she was great.
We'd have her explain
the project.
It was very important for me to
try and be as intuitive as
possible, so people come.
They look.
And they say, OK, this
is the effect line.
I'm supposed to press Play
so that it will start.
So it was also trying to be as
clear as possible, but also
trying to be as inviting
as possible.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: Actually, one
of the most interesting
decisions that we came
to, I think, the
day before the event.
Our original plan was to put a
laptop in front of the people,
the visitors.
But we decided to only put a
mouse there so that people
will be very constrained
in what they do.
And actually, people still
can't wait to escape our
sandbox of [INAUDIBLE], but--
and start playing.
So we understand that
it was really
easier with only a mouse.
People knew exactly what
they needed to do.
IDO GREEN: Thanks.
And so we talked about
the artistic aspects.
Maybe we can talk a bit more
about the technical aspects or
what were the main challenges.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: Well, the main
challenge in our piece of
work is we are pushing two video
streams, which is pretty
hard even on mobile CPUs,
a browser, of course.
And even more, we're doing
pair frame effects, like
[INAUDIBLE]
and inverting colors.
And doing everything in about
33 milliseconds was hard on
some of the computers
we tried it in.
The kind of computer that was
provided for us was only an 83
CPU, and it kind of lagged.
It wasn't a smooth 30
frames per second.
It was more like 15, 20
And as you pile on the effect,
it gets worse and worse.
So that was a real challenge.
And some other challenges were
syncing the audio and video,
which was very important
for Emmanuel for the--
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: For
the experience.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: --for
And it's totally
understandable.
But we couldn't actually have
it screen from the network
because then everything will
download at different times.
It's about five audio streams
and two video streams.
So they'll never sync.
So we ended up running it on the
local web server and then
copying it, saving the actual
file into a remote server, for
replaying stuff like that, which
was actually one of the
awesome features that I don't
think anyone ever used.
But they're actually there.
You can replay whatever
decisions you
made during your tour.
IDO GREEN: So you could go and
undo several elections, or
just do a replay of it?
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: You can
do a replay then add.
It saves all your steps.
Like at second 23, you
chose [INAUDIBLE].
At second 30, you
turned it off.
IDO GREEN: You talked about a
point that I think is very
interesting.
What method are you
using in order to
make the syncing work?
What have you attached to the
other parts, for instance, to
make sure that you truly
sync with the video?
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: Well,
basically, since everything
was already preconstructed, it
was basically a matter of
deciding and then placing
and then sort
of having a go situation.
But I have to also say that
this is actually an
interesting sort of question
from a more, I would say, meta
point of view.
Because the connection between
Devart and Fresh Paint was
interesting from my specific
perspective.
I don't know how this was
for you in your project.
But Fresh Paint were leaning
towards a result with me.
Whereas Devart or Google
were saying we're
interested in the process.
And I'm very interested
in the process.
And so to me, in a way, we had
sort of a hybrid between the
results and the process.
And I would really have loved a
situation where things could
have been more open ended, where
things could have been
more different, where you could
actually-- so instead of
replaying the whole
thing, replay--
OK, I just want this 10 seconds
because that was
really interesting, what
happened there, et cetera.
So the project is still
in process.
And I think that Devart
is exactly that.
It's an invitation to experience
a process.
So in a way, for
us, this was--
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: Yeah.
I think actually it crossed
the threshold, where more
people visited the site after
Devart than doing the actual
Fresh Paint event.
Because if I remember correctly,
we had 600 views
during the event.
And it's something
like 1,200 now.
So it's still active,
at least.
URI SHAKED: You are right.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: I'm not sure
what the user experience is
since it's in a very small
server right now But it's
really going.
IDO GREEN: Very nice.
And have you had some challenges
on things that you
started that you might have
been thinking of very high
from the macro view of things,
and then things didn't really
work as expected?
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: There
were a lot.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: 12.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: Yeah.
Definitely like a constant
negotiation between what we
can do and what we can
do realistically.
We had something like two or
three weeks, sort of the
actual project since
I joined it.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: We began the
project sort of at a time
frame where it was
very difficult to
generate things alone.
I really wanted to create a
platform that would invite
other people to upload all of
your recordings of Jerusalem
and Tel Aviv.
And in the end--
to create an app, actually,
where people could sort of
create an mp3, 30 seconds,
upload it [CLAP]
with a geotag that says, OK,
it's this place on GPS and
everything.
And then we could actually
use this for the project.
We couldn't reach
that in time.
We didn't have enough time.
So that was something that
I would have loved
to be able to create.
And I think that we were
basically scrambling for time
a lot of the time through
the whole thing.
So it was a game of compromise--
of saying, OK,
I'm not going to give up on this
no matter what or, OK, I
can let this go.
And yeah.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: We have a very
fun feature, which I'm
really bummed it
isn't finished.
We had a tablet, and we wanted
to have people control it
using the tablet.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: Oh, totally.
Yes.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: Yeah.
That's one of the features I was
scrambling at 4:00 AM the
day before, trying
to make it work.
And I made it halfway there.
But I wasn't really
prepared on time.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: No,
but we literally--
I mean, the fair started
at 5:00.
At 5:01, we were still
at the ladder,
fixing everything, and--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IDO GREEN: Like any
great painter,
up to the last minute.
Tighten the last screw,
whatever.
Yeah.
Great.
And what type of technologies
did you choose and why, if you
could share a bit?
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: Uri, you
could do your talk?
Or I'll talk.
URI SHAKED: All right.
So first of all, let me tell
you about the project I
participated in.
Emmanuel gave you
a teaser before.
In my project, the direction was
by moving inside the room.
The project was called--
still called the SoundTracker.
And the idea behind it is to
let the participants create
music by moving around
inside a room.
So usually, it takes a musical
instrument and years of
training in order to play
something that is
clever to the ears.
So we wanted to create an
experience that will let
anybody just walk into the
room and join into a live
orchestra, interacting with
other people in this same
space and creating music
as a consequence of
moving inside the room.
So before I'm going to talk
about the technology, let's
talk a little about--
I will tell you a little about
the obstacles we had.
We had many of them.
First of all, we worked
with a music artist.
And he wanted to create as
many tracks as eight.
But then we realized that the
average person without musical
training can't tell what his
specific role is when there
are too many instruments
playing at once.
So we had to cut down to four.
And that actually solved a lot
of problems that we had.
In order to find out where the
people are in every specific
moment-- what is their position
inside the room--
we tried several approaches.
And every single approach-- we
had a problem that the more
people we had, the approach
failed more times.
Because people were hiding
by each other.
And we tried several
alternatives.
The beginning, we started with
putting hats on the people, on
their heads, and using a camera
above to recognize the
location of each of the
people in the room.
We tried to take advantage of
the open source OpenCV, Open
Computer Vision.
That is a library.
But it wasn't accurate enough.
So we tried a whole different
approach.
Instead of using simple image
accumulation to recognize the
hats and LEDs-- the light
emitting LEDs
we had on the hats--
we changed to using full
body rests with
some sort of QR codes.
And then we found a great open
source-- not open source, but
free library from Qualcomm
that's called Vuforia.
And it's provided free for
both Android and iOS.
So we shifted our approach from
using computer processing
to actually do the processing
on a set of Android devices.
We had Android tablets hanging
all around the room from
different provisions, and they
constant are taking pictures
of the room and analyzing the
pictures, looking for these QR
codes, using this
Qualcomm SDK.
And then we used a main
server, which tried to
integrate the information from
all the tablets and create a
track of music by letting each
person control their
individual instrument--
like drums, guitar, piano,
synthesizer--
using his position and the
state of his movement.
We will add videos where you
will be able to see people
interacting with it.
Now one of the most interesting
aspects for us was
the fact that people didn't
quite interact
with it as we expected.
We thought that people will try
to come into the room and
then will just walk around
and see what happens.
And we found out that different
kinds of people
interacted in different ways.
For example, there were people
who just walked every one step
forward, then looked what
happened, another step
forward, then looked
what happened.
And the system was not designed
to identify such
small movements.
So we put shapes on the edges of
the floor in order to make
them move from shape to shape.
So they tried to jump between
the shapes without--
they turned it into
a kind of game--
without touching the floor or
sort of swimming the air or do
really cool things.
And then we found that our best
audience was children,
who really enjoyed running
all around.
And I'm not sure whether they
really understood the relation
between their position
and the music.
But they enjoyed it.
That's for sure.
And also there were sort of some
old people who started
looking around and
then seeing--
you saw like, OK, this
is the real color.
Guys, this is different.
This is not just walking from
one room to another and
watching another painting
and saying wow.
This is really getting
us active,
getting us the full angle.
So that was the best thing
about the project, seeing
people who were interacting
immediately with it, who were
enjoying it, were starting
to dance around
and do crazy things.
And I think that's what
we wanted to achieve.
And I think that we
succeeded in that.
IDO GREEN: And you were just
speaking about the technical
stack that you used.
URI SHAKED: Yeah.
So for the audio, we wanted
the audio to follow the
location of people
in the room.
So if they are, for example,
controlling the piano, we
wanted them to hear the piano
from the same position as they
were standing in, from
the same speaker
where they were standing.
So we had to use the OpenAL
library that provides a 3D
audio spot.
And in order to use the OpenAL
library from within Java, we
had to create Java bindings
to the library.
There were some very old Java
bindings which didn't work
well with our environment.
So we started a new open source
project that is Java
bindings for OpenAL,
Java OpenAL.
And this is a result
of the Devart.
We now have it on GDocs
so we can--
IDO GREEN: Yeah, we'll show a
bit later some of the project.
URI SHAKED: Check it out
if you are interested.
And we also used
the FluidSynth.
It's a sound synthesizer that
lets you synthesize sounds
from musical instruments
on the fly.
So it was like the brain behind
the sound engine.
And we fed the position
information.
We translated it into a sequence
of play a note on
this instrument, stop playing
the note and so on.
And we fed that into
the FluidSynth.
It created the sound stream.
And then we took that sound
stream and fed it into OpenAL
in order to create the 3D sound
experience, where each
player controls a specific
instrument, both in the
position and in the way that
instrument's placed.
IDO GREEN: Nice.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: Well, ours
was a little different.
It was a web app.
It was done with HTML5
technology, JavaScript, and
especially the cameras and
video elements, which we
combined in very interesting
ways, like having three
canvases all feeding
one another.
And we also used Google Maps
for tour selection.
And basically we had a small
back end written in PHP to
save all the tours.
IDO GREEN: Very cool.
What would be the top--
I don't know-- three things
that you would recommend a
group that is coming to build
a cool project next year?
Maybe I will split it into the
artistic part of things and
the technical part of things.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: Begin with
the technical approach.
IDO GREEN: OK.
What is the most important thing
to pay attention to?
URI SHAKED: Well, I'm not sure
whether it's truly technical
or artistic.
But what we learned is it's very
important to let people--
if you are building something
interactive, as we did in our
both projects, let people, your
friends, your family,
interact with the system in an
early stage in order to figure
out whether they are interacting
with it in the way
that you planned.
Or maybe there is a
much better way to
interact with it.
So we will be able to build a
system to be the most fun--
or whatever your goal is--
as you build it, and not just
build it as you think it will
be appropriated and then get it
and see that it is used in
different ways you didn't
anticipate.
IDO GREEN: So, Emmanuel.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: Not me.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: Well, I think
my top advice is think
about the user.
Think about who is going to
stand in front of your project
or the experience
you will have.
And you should understand
that the crowd--
if you're a developer, the crowd
you see there is not
your usual tech-y crowd.
There are a lot of people who
are not fluent in computers.
And you need to make
it as smooth of an
experience as possible.
That's my top tip.
And also, of course, have fun
and do something crazy, which
is very important.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: I'll
take that last
crazy thing and yeah.
Be open to experiment.
Be open to it being a process.
Don't feel that you're coming
into a project and you're
supposed to tell the developer
what to do or have the
developer tell you what to do.
You're there to create
something together.
Think of A plus B makes C. And
the public can be the C. You
guys can be the C. The end
product could be the C.
Everything can be a C. But the
idea behind it is to try and
experiment and to try
to do something new.
And Devart is exactly,
I think, that.
IDO GREEN: No, absolutely.
And I think in Fresh Paint, we
had more than 40,000 people
that play and work with
the projects.
So that's a huge number, just to
think about the users that
will interact and would
participate in it.
Have you seen any other cool
project that you'd like to
share with us, really short?
URI SHAKED: Well, yes.
There were a dozen of other
interesting projects.
One of them was enabling the
audience, the guests in the
Fresh Paint event, to send text
messages that appeared on
a very wide display
inside a room.
And these message
grew into trees.
So you had trees of letters,
consisting of the messages the
audience sent.
And then once in awhile, when
the trees became too crowded,
you have seen them sink
into the ground.
And the monitors then get
black, like into night.
And then after a few
seconds, it was
like the sun was rising.
And everything started to grow
new from new text messages
that people sent.
IDO GREEN: Cool.
Any other things?
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: I really
like that project as well.
I thought it was beautiful.
IDO GREEN: Yeah, and I think
this project is on Chrome
Experiments.
So we'll show the
link as well.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: I liked that
there was a very simple
project that gave you
a controller.
And you could play Tetris
with [INAUDIBLE].
It was very interesting
and very fun.
Because, again, it was a
very simple experience.
Tetris is something that
everyone knows how to play.
And in GeekCon, which was
another conference, there was
a similar project which used
laser technologies to draw on
the building.
And the projector saves
that work of art that
you do with the laser.
So things like that that have
you create something and
interact with something that
is on a huge building, on a
huge wall is very fun.
IDO GREEN: Great.
Great.
So thank you very much
for your time.
And hopefully we'll see very
cool things next year.
URI SHAKED: Sure.
Thank you very much.
MICHAEL SVERDLIN: Thank you.
EMMANUEL WITZTHUM: Thank
you for having us.